all right let's have a look now it is
Islam it is long but if you are patient
with it it's actually not that
complicated I like to think about in
maths some problems look very
intimidating but they can be sort of
hard in two ways some problems they're
very small but they're deep it's like a
it's like a really deep pool and you're
like oh my goodness I have to soon
really got to get across here other
problems are very shallow but they're
just wired it just takes you ages to go
across but it's it's not challenging I
would put this question in the second
category gentlemen good to go this is
not conceptually difficult it's algebra
we're okay with algebra but you do have
to be patient with yourself and careful
as well so let's have a look top line
and heard for you say to get used to
this right I'm saying all right if I
want to find this derivative this
gradient function the way I will do it
is using this process I'm gonna use the
difference question here it is this big
awkward thing on the right and then I
take that difference question and I see
what happens to it when H gets really
teeny tiny as it gets towards zero
that's why the H has an arrow going
towards zero
I just do my substitution here and then
I expand you're gonna get quite used to
doing this and then you can see I get to
this line where all this stuff starts
cancelling like crazy you like oh this
is looking good this is promising and
then when I've divided through by H I
end up with this okay now when you look
at this object 2x plus h plus 3 we no
longer have this problem we started with
a division by zero you're like oh I
could just see what happens if H was
zero this thing I just kind of
disappears right leaving you with this
now let's think about this for a minute
so far we have by hand done this process
of finding a derivative okay
and I should point out and this is
actually worth writing maybe where you
wrote all that up right this process of
doing it by hand is called
differentiating remember that's the
whole name but breaking apart all the
algebra doing this in this very long way
is called differentiating by first
principles and the name is exactly what
it says it's like we're going back to
the basics with
making about gradient and so it takes us
forever to go through this but hopefully
you're starting to get a sense now that
we've done this three times there are
some patents let's have a thing about
this right the first derivative sorry
the first function that we looked at
just now this morning actually was x
squared minus 4x right does anyone
remember what its derivative was 2x
minus 4 okay that was our derivative our
gradient function the next one we had to
look at was 5x plus 1 what was the
derivative the gradient function it's
just 5 and then the one we just did over
here was x squared plus 3x plus 2 and
we've just determined that its gradient
function its derivative is 2x plus 3
okay
let's observe some things have a look at
everything in the first column and then
look at what happens as you
differentiate which puts you in the
second color ok anyone shout out
anything that they notice anything at
all so you can see terms are very
similar right it's like there's a lot in
common between them can anyone be more
specific about what they see it's income
ah okay coefficient of x is 2 & 2 here
this coefficient here the this minus 4
and this minus 4 I should highlight that
you should to write this minus 4 just
kind of jumps over here right and this 3
just jumps of it that's interesting what
else you see yeah recipe
we take one a space
legs left oh okay that was a really big
idea that wrasse injure says so let me
see if I can repeat it and then try and
unpack it here wrasse and said we have a
look at like the biggest extern over
here right if we think back to at
polynomials this is what we call the
leading term so it's got the highest
power in this case it's an X square then
there's an X then there's another x
squared over here when you go over to
the derivative it's like you are it's
like you reduce the power by one do you
see that the x squared it's not squared
anymore that's just there's just a
single X there this this one was extra
power of one what happens when you
reduce that by one X to the power of 0
which is just it's just a number isn't
it right and then the same thing seems
to happen here so I could actually draw
a parallel from this over to here by the
way the x squared became a 2x there and
this x squared also became a 2x squared
2x that's probably not a coincidence
what did you note about those days plus
one of this plus two did you notice
anything mad that what happened to it
just seems sort of vanish now think
about this for a second well you just
look at the algebra it's a bit hard to
see but I want you to think about it
visually right remember we said Oh wrong
color this guy here we got to the five
and you're like oh what's the point
right like the gradient is five what
difference is the plus one make to this
function here what difference does it
make if I changed it's like plus a
hundred what difference would that make
Geron here's 5 X plus 1 right thanks
plus 1 where would say 5 X minus 1 be
here to be down here right or say 5 X or
say 5 X plus whatever okay and when you
have a look at each of these right does
it not seem the gradient is the same
across everyone it's just their position
that changes right so you can see here
when you go from the original function
to its gradient you don't care about
where it is can I say that again
when you're looking from the original
function to the grading you don't care
where it is
you just care about how fast is you save
bolt running does that make sense how
fast is this changing what's the
difference okay it doesn't matter where
he started if he starts in Beijing or
Berlin or whatever it's how quickly does
he move right but this plus two does
that do same deal right it's just moving
the parabola it's just moving it up and
down we don't care where it is up and
down we care about is it Steve is it
shallow is it going up is it going down
does this make sense okay